i was working at walmart
and
um i got a call from my friend and he's
like yo
cole just hit me up and said he [ __ ]
with your music and i'm like bro that
makes no sense why the hell would cole
hit you up and tell you that he [ __ ]
with my music and this was the time
where you know on twitter you had to be
following somebody
yeah so i guess cole had found my music
and he
i wasn't following him so he found the
closest person that i was talking to
like the most recent person i was
talking to and that was my friend so he
did my friend was following him because
he was a cold fan so
um so he just hit your random homie yeah
he hit my homie i was like yo tell your
boy i [ __ ] with this music tell them
holla at me so my boy hitting me you
know like yo i'm sitting like bro you're
full of [ __ ] bro cause it's just your
normal homie
about my music and
he just kept hitting me about something
like let me when i when i went on my
lunch break i'm like what the [ __ ] you
talking about so as soon as i add cold
cold hit me it's like yo we have to feel
more this weekend pull up and i'm gonna
let you know how i found your music and
that's how it started what year was this
this was 20
either 2012 or 2013.
damn so this was this was almost 10
years ago yeah we're knocking i want to
say it was 2012. so that was he had nine
years ago yeah wow
that's crazy yeah for cia i was like
damn like that's nuts so when people
like yo how did how did this happen i'm
like bro i can't tell you i don't know i
don't know how is that friend um
still your friend yeah i still my boy
amazing yeah that's the best yeah that's
my brother